ايضا نتابع هذا هذه المساله الحقيقه من
الطرفين الجانب الاسرائيلي ايضا يستعمل
كما ذكرنا قبل قليل قنابل ذات حجم تدميري
اوسع قد يكون الهدف منه
الحاضنه الشعبيه وفصائل المقاومه ايضا
تلقي برسائل من خلال استعمال لاسلحه قد
يكون ايضا ضمن خطه امنيه من قبل هذه
الفصائل طبيعه الحال عبد القادر اليوم كان
هناك تحول نوعي في هذه المواجهه حيث
استخدمت سرايا القدس لاول مره مضادات
للطيران كما اعلنت الاذاعه الاسرائيليه
هناك تفاصيل مهمه في هذا الشان اذا
المشاهدين الكرام كما ذكرنا سرايا القدس
لاول مره في هذه الجوله تستخدم مضادات
الطيران وفق ما اعلنت الاذاعه الاسرائيليه
ولكن ايضا هناك كان اطلاق
فمضاده للدروع في المنطقه الشماليه من
قطاع غزه وفق ما اعلن الجيش الاسرائيلي
وقذيفه مضاد الدروع هذه كما اعلن الجيش
دون ان يحدد المكان بالتحديد ولكنه قال
استهدفت المنطقه الشماليه من قطاع غزه
واحدثت حريقا لكنها قالت في الوقت نفسه
انه لم تقع اي اضرار او اصابات ولكن كان
هناك اليوم حديث لافت للنظر في مستوطنات
الشمال قطاع غزه او الشمال الشرقي لقطاع
غزه وما حولها عندما نتحدث عن هذه المناطق
فنحن نتحدث عن كما ذكرنا ايزيموت
التي لا تبعد الى حوالي خمسه الى سته كيلو
مترات كان هناك قرارات من السلطات
الاسرائيليه بعدم خروج الناس من هذه
المنازل من منازلهم في هذه المستوطنات
هناك هذا الموضوع يذكر بقضيه كانت في حرب
2014 عندما تسلل مقاومون الى مستوطنه نحال
عوز معسكر نحال عوز الذي نشاهده على
الشاشه الذي لا يبعد الا بضعه كيلومترات
عن وسط قطاع غزه تسلل هؤلاء المقاومون
ودخلوا الى هذا المعسكر ونفذوا فيه عمليه
عسكريه لم تحدد حتى هذه اللحظه السلطات
الاحتلال في ذلك الحين كم عدد الجنود
الذين قتلوا ما يشير الى ان هذا موضوع قد
يتكرر في المنطقه الشماليه الشرقيه من
قطاع غزه وهو دخول مقاتلين من سرايا القدس
او من المقاومه الفلسطينيه الى هذه
المناطق وتنفيذ عمليات عسكريه هذا الامر
يحيلنا الى ان القوات الاسرائيليه
المتمركزه في هذه المناطق تقع ضمن دائره
الرؤيه ودائره الاستهداف المباشر بالنسبه
للمقاومه الفلسطينيه وهذا الامر يبدو انه
ان الاحتلال الاسرائيلي يخشى من تنفيذ
عمليات بشكل مباشر الى القوات الاسرائيليه
قوات الاحتلال في هذه المناطق في مستوطنات
غلاف غزه لنطلع اكثر على هذا الموضوع معنى
من عمان الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجيه
اللواء فايز الدويري ساتل اذا ما تحدثنا
عن جزئيه استخدام الصواريخ الجديده من
مضادات الدروع ولاول مره مضاد الطيران
التي تستخدمه شارع القدس كنا نعلم ان
كتائب القسام لديها مضادات طيران وحاولت
في الفتره الاخيره تثبيت قاعده اشتباك
بعدم دخول اي طيران لاج واء القطاع دون
التصاد لهم ولكن وصول مضادات الطيران
لسرايا القدس ودخولها الى المعركه الان
بالاضافه الى استخدام مضاد الدروع ماذا
يعني ونحن الان في اليوم الخامس او السادس
من هذه المواجهه
يعني هذا يعتمد نجاحه وفاعليته على العديد
من العوامل اولا اذا المعلومات دقيقه
وهناك صواريخ مضاده للطائرات ما هي
انواعها ما هي مداها ما هي الدرجه
التطورها لانه احنا الان عندما نتحدث عن
صواريخ التي تعود لسرايا القدس نحن نتحدث
عن صواريخ ايرانيه بالمجمل سواء فجر
ابابيل براق غيرها استخدم بها الهندسه
العسكريه العكسيه وتم انتاجها محليا بناء
على الهندسه العكسيه للاسلحه الايرانيه
فاذا كانت هذه الصواريخ موجوده هل مدى
فاعليتها ودقتها والاعداد المتوفره منها
واهليه وكفاءه من يستخدمها حتى هذه اللحظه
تم اطلاق لم يتم تقديم ايه معلومات يمكن
البناء عليها فيما يتعلق صواريخ ضد الدرع
كذلك الحديث يدور عن كورنيت كورنيت وصاروخ
روسي استخدمت الهندسه العكسيه في ايران
وقد تستخدم الهندسه العكسيه في من قبل
فصائل المقاومه في غزه وهذا الصاروخ يا
مداع من 500 متر الى خمسه ونصف كيلو متر
ويعتبر نصف اوتوماتيك وقود الصلب ويستخدم
بالتوجيه البصري وتم استخدامه من قبل حماس
في الحروب السابقه واصاب هدفه في حال
وجودها
والتاكد من فعاليتها وكفاءتها وحسن
استخدامها هذا سيكون رقما صعبا في
المعادله وهذا قد يكون نقطه اضافيه لانه
الان الحديث عن المفاوضات وتعثر المفاوضات
والمماطله نتنياهو هذا الامر يحتاج هذا
الامر يحتاج من الجهاد الاسلامي
يقدم شيع وهذا الشيء يجب ان يكون اما
صاروخ في العمق يصيب هدفا كما حدث في جنوب
تل ابيب او كما حدث بالامس وان سقط في ارض
خاليه في الجبال غرب القدس او ان يكون
هناك
نجاح فعلي في منطقه غلاف غزه باصابه هدف
عسكري باصافه موقع عسكري هنا لابد من
اعاده الحسابات وهنا يظهر الرقم الصعب
للسلاح الجديد سنه اللواء اذا ما تحدثنا
عن امكانيه دخول سرايا القدس الى تحول
نوعي في هذه العمليات هل يمكن القول
بالاشاره الى الاعلان السلطات الاسرائيليه
اليوم عن دعوه الاسرائيليين عدم مغادره
منازلهم في المستوطنات الشماليه الشرقيه
من قطاع غزه ايفيمز ومفلاسيم ان هناك
امكانيه لاعاده سيناريو 2014 ودخول او
تسلل مقاتلين كما في 2014 من ناح يه العوز
ان يتم هذا الامر فعلا ونحن نعلم ان هناك
كميه كبيره من الانفاق الفلسطينيه انفاق
المقاومه التي تدخل الى عمق الاسرائيلي هل
يمكن في هذه المعركه استخدام هذا السلاح
وادخال مقاتلين الى الاراضي الاسرائيليه
او مستوطنات غلاف غزه وتنفيذ عمليات
عسكريه في الداخل
يعني الان دعنا نتحدث ما جرى بعد ما
عمليه التسلل الى نحال عوز ما جرى بعدها
من احتياطات واحترازات اسرائيليه اسرائيل
بنت جدار خرساني في بعض المناطق عمقه تحت
الارض 30 متر
وفوق الارض عده امتار مزود بمستشعرات لكشف
الحركه واي عمل انفاق اذا دعني اقول ان
هذا الاجراء الاحترازي لا يمكن ان يكون
فاعل بدرجه 100% يمكن اختراقه ولكن عمليه
الاختراق اكثر صعوبه من فتره ما قبله لان
غزه تسمى مدينه الانفاق يقال ان بعض
التقارير اشارت الى 500 كيلو متر طول
الانفاق وهذه الانفاق موزعه بين انفاق
دفاعيه انفاق هجوميه انفاق للقيادات انفاق
للمرابط الصواريخ الى وصلات ما بين اذا
دعني اقول تسمى غزه مدينه الانصار يمكن
لهم ان ينجحوا ولكن احتماليه النجاح اقل
من قبل بناء الجدار شكرا جزيلا لك كنت
معنا من عمان الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي
لواء فايز وطبيعه الحال هذه تفاصيل مهمه
عندما نتحدث عن عن غزه فنحن نتحدث عن هذه
المنطقه 38 كيلومتر سبعه كيلو متر
واحد في المئه فقط من مساحه فلسطين
التاريخ